翻訳: keitaro hoshino
校正: Kyoko Kamura
突然ですが 私から
皆さんに質問があります
この中で 何か募金を
したことがあるという方
手を挙げていただけますか
（挙手）
ほとんどの皆さんが
ありがとうございます
何か募金をしたときに
私もそうなんですけれども
自分の心が満たされるような
何か自分の気持ちがキラって輝くような
そんな気分になる人も多いと思います
それは きっとほとんどの皆さんが
常に誰かの役に立ちたいと思いながら
毎日生活しているからだと思います
それでは質問を変えます
目の前に困っている人がいて
その人への「支援」が大好きで
ワクワクするという方
手を挙げていただけますか
（挙手）
ちょっとさっきより少なくなっていますね
ありがとうございます
きっと今私の口から
「支援」という言葉が出た途端に
一気にハードルが上がってしまうような
ちょっと身構えてしまうような
そんな気分になった方も
いらっしゃるんじゃないでしょうか
実際 昔
私もそうだったんです
「支援」
それは強い人とか 力がある人 —
つまり ものすごく特別な人が
弱い人を助けてあげること
それが支援だと思っていました
でもそんな支援に対するイメージがあるとき
すっかり変わる経験をしました
そして 今私がイメージしている
支援の形は これです
お互いに補い合うような形
それは決して
一方的なものではありません
「支援」
それは 強い人が弱い人を
一方的に助けてあげることではなく
お互い つまり支援する側にとっても
足りないものを
補い合えるということです
これだけを今日覚えて
帰っていただきたいと思います
今から10年前の話をします
私が大学１年生のときでした
社会的に弱い立場にある
様々な人々について学ぶ授業をきっかけに
タイ 台湾 中国 フィリピン
４ヶ国の日本に住んでいる
アジア人のお母さんたちと
出会うきっかけがありました
そのとき お母さんたちは
自分の強みをテーマに
話し合いをしていたんですけれども
日本に住んでいて
すごく困っている話
悩み事の話や
自分に自信がない
そんな話ばっかりで
もちろん 自分から
「自分の得意なことはこれです」と
言えるような雰囲気では
ありませんでした
そんなお母さんたちの
姿を見たときに
すでにお母さんたちは数十年 —
長い方だともう20数年間
日本で暮らしています
なのに 何でこんなに
お母さんたちは自信がないのか
きっと何かがお母さんたちの自信を
奪っているんじゃないか
そんなふうに思いました
だから私は そのときのお母さんたちと
１人ずつじっくり話をすることにしました
すると分かったことがありました
お母さんたちが異国の地 —
この日本で生活する中で
抱えている問題というのは
すごく複合的なもので
私たち日本人が普通に生活している中では
気がつかないような問題を
多く抱えていました
例えば 子育ての問題
お母さんは日本語を
うまくしゃべることができません
でも 日本で産んだ自分の子どもは
日本で成長していくので
ある瞬間から お母さんよりも
日本語が上手になります
すると子どもは —
例えば 小学校で
何か嫌なことがあったとき
何か宿題を出されたとき
お母さんに相談しようと
するんですけれども
それに対してお母さんは
うまく日本語で伝えることができません
すると 子どもは段々とお母さんのことを
馬鹿にしてしまいます
そしてコミュニケーションが
取れなくなってしまう
次に 夫婦間の力関係の問題
言葉の壁や知り合いの少なさから
お母さんたちは家に
引きこもりがちになってしまいます
お母さんたちにとって家っていうのは
本当に唯一 落ち着ける場所であるのに
その居場所である家の中でも
段々と旦那さんとの力関係が
大きくなってしまって
旦那がお母さんに
暴力を振るうようになってしまう
そんな問題
そして最後に
働く場所がないという問題
お母さんたちは 片言でコミュニケーションを
取れるだけの日本語を話すことはできます
そういう方は
たくさんいらっしゃいます
でも 日本語を読んだり書いたり
漢字とかですね
[これが]できる方がいるかというと
すごく少ないです
すると 日本では働ける場所とか
職種っていうのが
すごく限られたものになってしまいます
今話した３つの問題は
本当に 一部の問題だと思っています
そんな話をお母さんたちから
聞いているときに思ったこと
それは 今まで力があったのに
異国の地の日本に来た途端に
自分１人の力で できないことが
あまりにも多すぎて
そうすると もちろん
自信を失ってしまうし
もう本当に最終的には
自分の価値って何なんだろう？と
思うようになると思います
世界では 様々な社会問題が
あふれています
でも お母さんたちの
抱えている問題 —
それは光が当たっていないと
思いました
光が当たっていないから
彼女たちの問題に目が向かない
そして目が合わない
そんな社会で私は暮らしたくない
そう思いました
だからお母さんたちが輝ける瞬間とか
お母さんたちに光を向けること
これってどうやったらできるんだろう？
ずっとそれを考えました
すると お母さんたちが
輝ける瞬間というのは
すぐに見つかりました
お母さんたちは ミーティングで
集まるときに自分の国の料理 —
母国料理をお家で作って
タッパーに入れて
私達に食べて欲しくて
よく持ってきてくれました
私は当時 大学１年生で
エスニック料理を食べるのが
そのときが本当に
初めてだったんですけれども
すごく驚きました
甘かったり 辛かったり
酸っぱかったり
言葉で表現できないような
刺激的な味なんですけど
とにかく 本当に美味しいんです
お母さんたちは 自分の国の
料理の話をしているときに
すごい誇らしそうにしています
普段だったら自分の日本語が伝わるかな
という気持ちが先に来てしまって
なかなか日本語をしゃべってくれないことも
あるんですけれども
自分の国の料理を説明するときは
すごく積極的に話をしてくれます
それはなんでかというと
自分の作った料理のことを伝えたいから
自分の生まれ育った国のことを
伝えたいから
すごく楽しそうに
話してくれました
そんな姿を見たときに お母さんたちが
生まれ育った国だからこそ
文化だからこそ
環境だからこそできる
目の前にある
すごくおいしい料理
これが 必ずお母さんたちの
自信を取り戻せる —
大きなきっかけになるんじゃないかと
確信しました
当時 私は大学生だったので
大学の中で１日限りの
お母さんたちの料理を販売するような
屋台のイベントを
企画することにしました
ここで とある台湾人のお母さんの
話をしたいと思います
彼女の名前は游（ゆう）さん
游さんは日本で
数十年間暮らしていますが
自分ひとりで
どこかに出かけるとなると
自分の家から 夜ご飯とか
ご飯の食材を買いに行く
市場までの徒歩10分圏内
電車ももちろん乗れませんし
十数年間 日本でその徒歩10分圏内の
往復しかしていない
それを聞いたとき 私は単純に
ものすごく驚きました
そんな游さんなんですけれども
この屋台のイベントで
游さんの得意な台湾の焼きビーフンを
作ってもらうことにしました
ただ 游さんは
本当に自信がなかったです
自信がなかった理由は
まさか 屋台なのでお金を払って
日本人が自分の国の料理を
食べてくれるはずがない
今まで友達とか数人の子にしか
ビーフンを振舞ったことがないから
何十食も作ることはできない
やったことがないし
できないし そんなわけないし
本当に ないないだらけの
游さんでした
集客は100人以上を見込んでいた
その屋台イベントなんですけれども
何度も游さんに説得を重ねて
作ってもらったビーフンの数 —
それは 30食
朝から夜までのイベントなので
すぐに売り切れるに決まってるんですけれども
游さんにとっては
全部が初めてで
初めて作る何十食のビーフンは
本当に大きなチャレンジだったと思います
そして 実際にイベントが始まって
開始30分で游さんのビーフンは
もちろん売り切れてしまいました
私達もそうだなとは
思っていたんですけれども
そんな体験をした游さん
そんな游さんが言った言葉は
あれだけ作れないって
言ってたのに
「なんで もっと作らなかったの」
という逆切れと
（笑）
「次は100食作る！」
70食以上 多くなってるんですけど
「100食作る！」という
大きな自信でした
そんな游さんの姿を見たときに
それは游さんだけじゃなくて
他のお母さんたちもだったんですけれども
本当にたった１回の
この屋台のイベントをきっかけに
お母さんたちは お客さんによって
自分の強みを認識して
大きな自信を手に入れた
そして 企画した私たち学生は
できるかすごく不安だったんですけれども
実際 お客さんが
たくさん来てくださって
それって自分たちがこんな
イベントをするという 伝える力に
お客さんが集まってくれた
だから自信がついた
そんな経験をしました
「支援」と聞くと
なんか大変そうで
自分ごとにはできないかもしれません
でも 初めに質問をさせて
いただいたように
募金をしたときとか
例えば 電車で誰かに席を譲ったときに
自分の気持ちがキラッと
ちょっとだけでも輝いた
そんな気持ちの延長線上に
お互いを補い合える —
「支援」の形があると思っています
互いに足りないところを
補い合う過程で気がつく —
自分の強みや弱み
そして 何よりも自分の価値
それらに気がつくと
支援する側 支援される側
そういった関係を超えて
お互いに力を引き出し合おうとします
そして それはお互いに
ワクワクできるんです
ただ目の前の問題が
解決するだけではありません
そんな お互いがワクワクできること
これを私はこう呼んでいます
「エンパワーメント」
そんなエンパワーメントのきっかけを
もっとたくさん
もっと継続的に
たくさん作るためにはどうしたら良いか
そう考えて 私はそのときに生涯かけて
そういう場所を作ろうと心に決めました
そして今 私は
神戸の南京町で
『神戸アジアン食堂バルSALA』という
小さなアジアン食堂を営んでいます
８ヶ国 17名のスタッフと一緒に
作り上げているお店です
大学時代に屋台の
イベントを企画してから
お互いに補い合う
支援を続けた結果
このお店では たくさんの
「エンパワーメントの連鎖」が起こっています
当時「ビーフンは30食しか作れない」
そう言っていた 台湾人のお母さんは
十数年の月日を経て 今では
SALAで看板シェフとして
毎日頑張ってくれています
そして なんと来年度には
游さんの夢でもある
台湾料理の専門店を
出店することも決まりました
この絵はSALAの入口に
描かれた壁画です
お店のコンセプトに共感してくれた —
フィリピン人アーティストのセシルさん
という方が 直接壁に描いてくれました
この絵のテーマは
「Empowerment of All People」
全ての人々が
エンパワーメントされる世界
セシルさんがこの絵に
込めていただいた思い
それは 国籍も関係なくて
男性も女性も
また妊婦さんも子どもも
それぞれが それぞれの立場から
お互いの価値を認め合い
そして何よりも 自分自身の価値を
認めることができる世界
かつて ないないづくしだった游さん
今では 当時の自分と
同じような境遇のお母さんたちを
輝かせる側になりました
そんな姿を見て 私自身も
大きく勇気付けられて
そして 私も輝きたいと
思えました
そんなふうに輝いている人を見て
自分も輝きたいと思う
そんな輝きの連鎖を引き起こすこと
それがお互いに補い合う
支援の形だと思っています
お互いに輝くことができる
「エンパワーメントの連鎖」を
今日 この会場にいる皆様とも
一緒に起こせることを
強く願っています
（拍手）